[Music]  almost done with my Christmas list for  Jenny I'll just make her favorite  chocolate chip cookies for Noah Noah  kind of already has everything  Noah I was literally just thinking about  what's here you for Christmas  by the way if we're gonna do this thing  we are gonna need it in contract oh it's  just a Christmas contract well then I  get to make the first rule I'm not  watching a Christmas horror movie no  it's the Christmas prints one and two I  can definitely do that one more thing I  get to tell the fans about our lives  okay okay go for it I am so excited and  it's officially official we are making  it beep to all the boys see right now in  the sequel we are so excited know once  again I'll be back okay sure  Hey what you're gonna make the perfect  done Ambrose  you  you